et bien voilà nous nous retrouvons de
dire que j'ai du mal à me lever
aujourd'hui c'est julien lepers je
remplace william leymergie pendant ces
vacances qui l'a bien mérité bonnes
vacances repose toi bien william on est
ensemble pour une bonne semaine de
télématin tous les jours sur antenne 2
jusqu'à 9 heures et je veux dire que
lorsque williams m'a téléphoné pour me
dire julien est ce que tu veux pas me
remplacer je pars en vacances et tout ça
tu verras ça sera bien j'ai accepté avec
plaisir parce que je connais bien les
missions il se passe des tas de choses
c'est très varié notamment aujourd'hui
il y aura le temps des campagnes en
trouvera michalis dans un moment on
aurait une séquence port avec le
grass-track je vous expliquerai ce que
c'est c'est la moto sur herbe
ça vient des états unis ça va très vite
on en parlera dans un moment cinéma
vidéocassettes bien sûr la séquence nos
enfants avec patricia de marchi faut-il
montrer ses émotions à ses enfants la
colère la peur la tristesse la joie on
verra tout ça aussi tout à l'heure
dessin animé bien sûr sylvestre et titi
rubrique santé avec nos cinq sens
aujourd'hui on parlera de l'oreille et
de l'audition rubrique tourisme avec le
périgord le feuilleton d'été bien sûr
que tout le monde attend fortunata et
assata nos points journaux avec isabelle
beige clair que je connais bien je
saluerai tout à leur donner le compte
aussi mais aujourd'hui c'est le jour
férié aujourd'hui on est vendredi 15
août 1986 jours fériés fête religieuse
très importante c'est la fête de
l'assomption la sainte marie la fête de
la vierge c'est le pèlerinage national
aujourd'hui à lourdes
et pour ce faire notre invité notre
grand invité du jour sera le chanoine
du chapitre de la cathédrale de tarbes
en recevra le père raymond lavedan bonne
matinée à tous tes les matins jusqu'à 9
heures
op
hugo